Uh,
today we've got doctor Penelope Boston joining us from,
uh,
just next door over at NASA ames.
Uh,
she's the director of the NASA astrobiology institute and we'll be here talking
today a little bit about our research.
Great.
Cool.
Welcome.
Okay,
thanks Kelvin.
I'm really happy to be here,
uh,
to share a few thoughts,
with everybody about,
uh,
one of the most challenging things that we're trying to do at NASA and in fact
other space agencies around the world and that is,
uh,
trying to hunt for extra terrestrial life.
And of course we've been doing this for a number of decades.
Um,
uh,
both within NASA,
within the university and a research lab environment.
And um,
Europe is highly involved in this and other countries are coming on board.
Um,
Japan has a very active,
um,
a space program and a lot of interest in astrobiology as,
uh,
do people in China and many other parts of the world.
So this is really a global enterprise,
but I'm going to give you a really my own perspective on where the robbing
points are.
Looking for life is extraordinarily difficult because life is not really a
collection of stuff.
It's a collection of stuff.
Those actually behaving in the time dimension.
So it's an ongoing process and this means that it is
at one sense flamboyant.
We live on a planet that's actually a saturated with life.
This,
our planet is dominated by life.
But if we have a life on other bodies in our solar system,
it clearly isn't the same kind of,
uh,
global dominating force that it is here.
And so this really changes the game and a lot of the work that those of us in
the,
in the science community have done on this,
uh,
have to do with looking at examples that we have on this planet that are,
um,
very challenging.
So marginal environments,
extreme environments on our planet has really sort of set the stage for trying
to expand our,
our thinking in that regard.
Um,
we really want a tricorder where you just point your device at something and it
tells you a bunch of wonderful stuff.
But we actually really,
uh,
are still fumbling around in many cases with,
more like a Rube Goldberg device.
And this is the cartoon that actually started,
um,
the idea of these crazy devices that Rube Goldberg who was a famous artist and
and cartoonist actually came up with back in the 1930s.
So we often refer to Rube Goldberg devices as some kind of kluged together
thing.
So even though we have many a technologies that we are,
that we are working with because life is a subtle phenomenon and we don't know
what it's going to be made on other planets and we don't know even what it's,
um,
pace of life and many other things about it are actually going to be like we are
trying to design a instrumentation and protocols and accessibility to places
that we are tremendously unfamiliar with and where the life might be so
different in its many different properties.
That trying to even recognize it as life might be very challenging.
Now I could go the other way.
It could be that there's something so optimized about the way our life does
chemistry,
that it's the only road available.
I don't personally believe that,
but there are people who do believe that.
But really these are articles of faith at this point rather than really
informed,
uh,
stances.
So that's the background.
So what are we looking for?
Well,
we're looking for things that are still alive.
If they were cute and green with three eyes like a,
these guys from the movies,
that would be easy.
The truth is that they're much more likely to be microbial organisms.
And one of the reasons that we think so,
of course,
is because really for three quarters of the time that we have evidence of life
on our planet in the rock record,
it was microbial life,
big things like us.
We're,
um,
uh,
decorative,
additional afterthoughts that happened after many different cycles of geological
changes had occurred over hundreds and hundreds of millions of years,
billions of years.
So it wasn't until between seven and 800 million years ago that what we would
now call complicated,
multicellular things began to be,
uh,
evolving.
And this is on a planet where we have evidence of life back to at least 3.6
possibly 3.7 and possibly 3.8 depending,
uh,
evidence from that period of time.
It's really subtle and really hard to interpret.
But anyway,
the bottom line is it was a heck of a lot longer ago then.
Then we have big things.
So this pushes us in,
into the realm of microbiology.
On the other end of the spectrum,
of course,
we are also looking for evidence of past life.
And I don't know if there are any amateur paleontologists in the room,
but if so,
you'll know that the way you look for fossil material is very different from the
way you studied living material.
And yet we have both of these twin goals,
uh,
because we don't know what we're going to find.
And even though we would all love to find a actively living organisms somewhere
in our solar system,
we'd still be very happy if we found convincing evidence of even past life,
for example,
on Mars.
So one of the biggest problems is that if you take a physics and chemistry
perspective,
this is very instructive,
accept that life is really not a package of bulk properties.
So in many cases we are measuring bulk properties of a planet and buy bulk.
I don't mean uh,
you know,
things the size of California,
I mean bulk things that are above the microbial scale.
So micro organisms are individually very tiny,
although they can be,
uh,
macroscopically visible in the aggregate,
but in very low nutrient environments where,
uh,
the numbers of organisms are very low,
you have patchy distributions that are hard to explain.
You know,
the obvious thing is if you have a nutrient gradient,
you would expect organisms to be arrayed along that nutrient gradient.
And there is some of that,
but there's also a more magical properties that life has,
which seemed to have something to do with self organizing properties of complex
systems.
And they do not just,
you know,
trivially map onto what is available for them.
And this is something that a number of folks in the community are studying,
but we really don't have a grasp of it.
So why am I talking to you about this?
Other than the,
um,
working at NASA currently,
I have spent most of my career working in extreme environments and for the past
25 years or so,
I have focused primarily on the subsurface and natural caves and minds.
I'm not gonna spend a lot of time on my work,
but I just want to show you a few examples,
some of our more photogenic examples,
um,
that try to look at the most extreme physical and chemical conditions that we
can find on our planet in an environment in the subsurface where photosynthesis
is not possible.
So our focus has always been on the micro organisms that make their living not
off organic materials,
but off inorganic materials.
They're essentially rock eaters and they get their various,
um,
energy quantum by quantum,
by doing things like oxidizing metals in,
in minerals.
So this is a geologically driven,
a source of energy for these organisms.
And as we look around our solar system,
we see no where else that is green and gooey like our planet.
And so the fact that we have photosynthesis as our primary driver of the energy
that goes to run our biosphere is very lucky for us.
That's why we're all sitting here.
But on a planet with a much more subdued a potential biology,
we're not going to see that.
And we know that we don't have anywhere else like earth that we can find in our
solar system.
So we're looking for a much more subtle,
much lower biomass systems,
perhaps functioning at a much a slower level.
So we go places like in the,
uh,
the upper left hand corner.
This is a cave that we have studied in Tabasco,
Mexico for,
uh,
almost 20 years now,
starting in 1998.
And this system has dominated by sulfuric acid.
It has hydrogen sulfide pouring into it from a number of springs and um,
that goes into a reaction with oxygen in the system,
in the water and in the air and produces sulfuric acid.
So it's a hyper acidic environment and that's where we're all duded up in the
suits and so forth.
Um,
and the breathing masks and,
um,
auxiliary oxygen bottle so that we can actually survive in there long enough to
do the work that's actually very chemically extreme.
It's not temperature extreme.
So if you go to the upper right hand side,
you can see that we're working in another environment.
This is a much newer project on the flanks of Mount Rainier.
There's a lot of mountaineering involved in getting up there.
There are a permanent ice caves that are the result of being in an IC
environment,
but these are a volcanic fumaroles.
Mount Rainier courses are very large and gorgeous volcano.
Um,
that is definitely still active,
although it hasn't erupted in a good long time,
but it will again someday.
And in the meantime it's got a lot of the similar gasses,
but these,
you're coming out into a very cold environment.
And then the lower left has been the focus of a lot of national geographic
expeditions that we have,
um,
had been part of.
And,
uh,
we have explored these giant crystals in a very hot environment.
So,
uh,
this is on the order of between 40 and sixties,
um,
Celsius.
Um,
the hottest that we've had in there is a in excess of 60 degrees c to the point
where one of my former graduate students got a second degree burns when one of
her boots ruptured.
So that's pushing in the very hot direction.
There are things in the subsurface of earth that are unsuspected in the surface.
And so it's almost like going to another planet every time you go into one of
these extraordinary environments.
And that has been very helpful in my own thinking about imagining these
different kinds of conditions combined in various different ways and how you
would go about actually trying to find these in,
um,
uh,
you know,
alien terrain and certainly robotically for the foreseeable future.
Ultimately,
perhaps we will have humans on Mars that can actually do some of this
exploration,
but for a good long time we're not going to be able to do it other than with our
devices that we send there.
So this is a wordy slide,
but I want you to really focus on the colored,
um,
uh,
words.
These are the high level thing.
So we talk about biosignatures,
meaning anything that leaves behind,
and this is can be as subtle as metabolically produced gases that you see here
in this list.
Obviously the gold standard would be if we could actually find live organisms,
but much more subtle accumulations of suggestive biological molecules that we
know are a part of our biology here.
Possibly molecular fossils.
These are traces of organic materials that we know at least on earth are
associated with various different kinds of organisms might be preserved and
things like,
uh,
a silicate materials or carbonates.
And of course if we find true fossils,
they're known as body fossils that are somehow recognizable by their structure
and not a,
a,
an artificial,
a mimic of a form of life that would be obviously the most strong type of
evidence.
But there are many other things that we see on earth that are the result of life
including biopack,
excuse me,
bio minerals that are produced by the activity of these,
uh,
rock eating and,
and mineral pooping out organisms that I was just mentioning.
And then other subtle Geo chemical traces that I will not go into the nitty
gritty details well on my life.
Oh meter on the left hand side you can see I've got sort of a slider bar from
extent life to extinct life.
So all these different kinds of pieces of evidence,
um,
either,
uh,
pertain more to the extinct life end of that spectrum and more or more to the
extent life,
uh,
guys that are still alive.
So the truth is about our,
our current grasp on life detection that we were really doing it by
circumstantial evidence.
We are looking at some of those weaker lines of evidence that I just quickly
flashed before you in the previous slide and looking for um,
uh,
places where we may find complicated organic compounds.
And I don't mean just simple amino acids,
I mean things that are more complex that we can imagine being a product of life
and the co location of those,
um,
or patterns of molecular or even suspicious patterns of um,
uh,
elemental abundances in one place.
But that's really still forensically a circumstantial piece of evidence,
right?
None of those things are really the clinchers.
You could go,
gee,
that looks really suspicious,
but if it isn't wiggling around,
you don't really know that it's life without a whole lot more work.
On the other hand,
of course it's very hard to find complicated structures.
So um,
this particular electron micrograph that you see there is from uh,
one of our lava tube caves that we've studied and they're pretty convincing.
They're fuzzy,
they look sort of like little chrysanthemums to me.
Although each one of those is about a micrometer in diameter.
So you could fit a hundred of those across the diameter of one of your hairs.
I'm so very,
very tiny and they appear in very patchy distributions in this lava tube cause
there isn't a whole lot for them to eat.
So what are our chances of being able to look at enough material on a robotic
mission to actually come up with those?
So you can begin to see this conundrum and we've got,
you know,
various different lines of evidence that we need.
But trying to get them all on the same sample or in the same time is really
challenging.
So I just show this as an example of the work of one of my colleagues.
And um,
uh,
in fact,
one of the team members of our,
one of our NASA astrobiology institute teams,
uh,
happens to be the one that,
is headed out of Seti right here.
And,
uh,
Richard spends a lot of his time worrying about how we're going to do life
detection,
has come up with a steps towards one of these analytical combinations.
And we're not going to go through this in detail,
but just to point out that he's trying to combine micro fluidics to actually get
access to a micro organism,
a sized creatures,
and at the same time use fluorescence to try to look for living materials.
Um,
very often,
of course,
we look for natural fluorescence or we look for fluorescence that we can
actually induce,
um,
by using various wavelengths or in fact even putting materials into,
uh,
the sample that will bind with biological compounds.
So we're making a lot of progress in the these lines.
But even this is not really a life detection.
It,
it is still piecing together a tiny bits of information about the chemistry and
hoping this is real life detection.
If something was big and it came up and bit you on the ankle,
that'd be pretty convincing.
And anything short of that is much less convincing.
And so the question for us is,
what is the suite of things that we need?
How many different lines of evidence do we need and how strong does that
evidence have to be to actually convince us at sometime in the future that we've
found an actual living creature?
Well,
this is not new.
This is a famous cartoon from the New Yorker,
a that was drawn in 1962.
Um,
very early on in the space age and the fundamental principles of what we need to
do are still the same.
It's really hard,
but we spend a lot of time trying to figure out what life forms you might get
from first principles given whatever properties you know about a particular
body.
So,
for example,
Mars,
we've had a long history of attempting to look for life on Mars.
Our first attempts in,
um,
in the early to mid 1970s were very naive in retrospect.
We didn't know that,
um,
this was before we'd even discovered that there were hydrothermal vents at the
bottom of the oceans.
Right?
We,
we did not know about the world of extreme of files,
um,
at that time,
but we did know that maybe on a planet there would be a very different
atmosphere and the creatures there would be using that.
So that notion is one that has been in people's minds for a long time.
So I just want to share with you some of my biggest concerns and where I hope
that,
um,
not only folks within NASA and the university communities,
but everybody within the tech realm,
uh,
that might be interested in,
in some of these,
um,
these issues,
could find a way to contribute.
So these are the five biggest problems that I see right now.
Simultaneous measurements,
you would think we would assault this.
We haven't,
um,
in terms of doing the kind of biology,
that we do in extreme environments or any environment on our,
we have missions that don't last that long and if they do last long,
we go to different places.
So the idea of long term observations to capture changes in things that might be
alive that may be living on a very,
very slow timescale and growing very,
very occasionally,
perhaps once every hundred years,
perhaps once every 10,000 years.
And we have examples of that in the Antarctic,
even on our own planet.
Uh,
the doubling time for cells that are living under sandstone,
um,
uh,
in sand stones in the Antarctic dry valleys probably only reproduce once every
20,000 years.
Well,
that's pretty darn hard to capture that,
um,
anywhere
and certainly on another planet.
So how do we solve that problem?
A problem three is access to challenging terrain as well.
It's robots.
I love robots and there's a wonderful community of robot designers that are
coming up with,
with,
um,
concepts that are,
you know,
certainly the kinds of things that we're going to need.
And yet,
what are we still flying?
Where's Fluor?
Flying a mini coopers basically.
Okay.
So we have to close the gap of trying to,
uh,
be able to do to tech demos and actually vet these kinds of much more creative
and much more capable robotic capabilities before we can fly them.
What you do on earth is one thing,
but getting something ready to be approved for space flight is a whole other
thing.
It's vastly more difficult.
It's vastly more expensive.
Problem four is essentially seeing like a human.
And by that I mean sensing and integrating at the same time,
particularly for the icy moons around the gas giants where we know that there
are,
uh,
liquid interiors of these and where there's a huge amount of,
circumstantial hope and evidence that these would be very habitable places on
the interior.
We,
um,
cannot direct these immediately on a step by step basis from Earth.
It's hard enough with Mars in terms of the delay in the return time of
commanding spacecraft and commanding payloads when you get out,
uh,
to the orbits of Saturn and Jupiter.
Uh,
the delay time just makes that ridiculous.
And in fact the interference from the radiation environment,
he's high radiation environments and the,
and the gas giants and the fact that,
um,
wherever your interrogating is going to be eclipsed by the planet episodes and
so forth,
that fluidity of communication that you need to actually run things from the
ground is simply not going to be there.
And this of course push it to the US in the direction of,
uh,
devices that can make their own decisions.
And then binding all these together is a thing called planetary protection.
I don't how many of you have ever heard of this term?
Um,
it is not planetary defense,
which is a related term that NASA has interests in.
Uh,
that's when we're thinking about near Earth asteroids slamming into us.
And what are we going to do about that?
This is on the other end of the spectrum and this has to do with microbiology.
And this
is a problem that was recognized right at the dawn of the space age and before.
And that is microbial life could potentially be a hazard to any life on another
planet if it comes from here.
And then in turn,
the reverse is also true and that is as we get to the era where we're bringing
back samples from,
uh,
astrobiology targets like Mars,
we want to make sure that we are not risking any,
uh,
adverse consequences for own one and only home planet.
So these are very serious issues and they have been taken very seriously.
NASA has a planetary protection officer and office with worries about this.
There is an international body called Cospar,
um,
that,
uh,
brings together the,
the global space community and one of its divisions of courses devoted to
planetary protection.
And in fact this year,
the COSPAR meeting this summer is actually going to be down,
um,
in the Pasadena area in southern California.
It travels all over the world.
The last one was in Turkey,
uh,
was intended to be in Turkey and that was just as the COO happened,
so that one was canceled.
But this is the body that deals with a lot of interactions and it deals with
this problem of how do we make sure that we're not screwing up somebody else's
planet and that we're not screwing up our own.
So this is a very serious problem.
So just a few details.
The simultaneous measurements,
we've got a lot of signal to noise problems.
It doesn't matter what kind of planet it is.
We've got issues with both of these.
Um,
we're looking at patching us that we don't understand.
As I mentioned before,
low biomass,
probably the life might be very cryptic that is,
I'm not recognizable to us and they might a thrash around at a very,
very slow pace compared to us.
And the minute you take a microbial sample,
even here on earth,
you have changed it.
And we try to compensate for that here on earth because we understand a lot more
about our own biology.
But we have found that a problem in extreme environments where we are poking
around at things that we don't know who's there,
we don't know how many are there.
It all looks like minerals or soil or something,
uh,
is only after a significant amount of work that you can actually prove that some
of these things are alive.
And some of those examples I show here from uh,
some of our previous work,
the stars that you see on the interior of each one of those manganese oxide
stars is a tiny micro organism and it causes the precipitation of that manganese
oxide as a byproduct of using other oxidation states manganese minerals to make
its living.
And it produces these characteristic things.
Um,
I can't tell you how many times this kind of work has to be submitted before you
can prove to yourself and other people that you really looking at a living
thing.
Because from the surface it just looks like a mineral.
The other end of the scale is we see things here on earth that we cannot
determine what they are.
And I show this thing that looks like a broken mesh stocking.
And we have found these kinds of structures literally all over the world in
every kind of geochemistry and every kind of temperature in caves,
in the subsurface.
And after 20 years of working on this,
we still don't know what they are.
They don't map onto any other kind of micro organism.
So even here we essentially are working with aliens in a way.
So the solution to this is really that we need simultaneous multispectral and
multiscale imaging and we need to have that done at the same time.
We're actually interrogating the chemistry and preferably something about the
energy state to look at what the in tropic condition is within a suspected
organism and all at the same scale that matters to microorganisms,
which is really very tiny.
It doesn't do you any good to look at one size of a hand sample rock on Mars for
one and the other side for another thing and the other side for another thing.
You cannot then overcome that logical conundrum of bringing those together to
really produce highly,
uh,
trustable,
high quality data that would convince us that it was a lie.
One of the things that may be helping us with this problem is,
is relatively new and it's the idea of not big spacecraft,
but whole fleets of tiny little things.
So here again we've got the cryptic life problem.
Are they even recognizable low biomass.
Again,
slow pace of life.
You can't invade them with clumsy sample handling because you might suppress
them or destroy them.
And we even have large scale patterns changing on geological timescales are
perhaps a little shorter.
And the,
the upper image shows one of the patterns that we've been working in.
If you look,
this is a,
the sulfuric acid cave in Mexico.
If you look at all the dark material,
you can see that it looks like little dots.
It's actually a hieroglyphic like pattern.
And this is something that is a self organizing property of microbial
communities,
which helps them distribute fluid flow and the distribution of nutrients and
other limiting,
uh,
other limiting factors.
We've been working on the mathematics of the development of this and then trying
to back what that means out scientifically from that work.
So we have all of these complicated things,
um,
the poof ball see which happens to be in a cave in southeast Alaska,
uh,
right around freezing.
Uh,
the white stuff that the hand is pointing to,
that's actually a shallow pool.
And those poof balls actually,
um,
are composed of a previously undescribed filamentous microorganisms that produce
these beautiful finish shaped,
uh,
calcium carbonate crystals that you see in there.
Well we've never seen anything like that before and trained to look for that
life signal when you're visual appearance of these poof balls are actually globs
of fluffy minerals.
So I show these pictures just to show you pretty how challenging this is even
here.
So we really need longterm monitoring and we are looking at things like small
sats,
smart breadcrumbs,
we don't know.
We need things that are self contained,
they don't have to do a lot,
but numerosity can overcome this problem of time,
dimension.
And it can also give us the basis for a statistical analysis.
If we can't sit there for 20,000 years,
we can do a statistical analysis of various phenomena and that will give us
insight into some of these.
Well now we get to the robots,
which I love.
I have a made a cottage industry before I went back into NASA when was still in
the university environment of essentially being the pet astrobiologist have a
lot of robot groups.
So I'm MIT and JPL and uh,
various other ones because people who are designing these wonderful robots,
they need to know what the customer base once.
And I am a customer and a very chatty customer and I love robots.
So,
um,
we want to be able to get into these difficult terrains.
In my case it's caves and a rock overhangs and things like that,
but even rugged terrain on the surface of the Enceladus for example,
or Europa,
um,
we have nothing that can do that at this point.
We need to be able to,
uh,
look at features of significance.
So,
uh,
RSLs are these recurring slope Lynnie I these streaky things that come and go on
Mars and appear to be brine or not.
Okay.
We don't even know what they are.
Maybe they're liquid and maybe they're not liquid.
So we have to be able to get up to those with,
um,
robotic devices that we can then remove.
Um,
and,
and do the analysis.
We want to be able to interrogate tiny environments and huge environments and
sensitive environments.
And the way to do that is with surrogates that are our robotic partners.
Um,
biologically sensitive environments,
even with astronauts on site.
Um,
these planetary protection protocols,
these planetary protection concerns means that it's not going to be like the
Martian where the guy has tromping around on Mars and walking up to things and
practically licking them.
I mean,
I know he was trying to stay alive,
but that's not the way to do science.
So that was a great adventure story,
but it's not the way to do astrobiology on Mars with astronauts.
And so we need surrogates to be able to go do that.
So one of the frustrations that I have and I know a lot of folks have is that,
um,
we really need to enhance the pace of being able to field test these access,
robots and other ways of expanding our ability to detect the environment.
And we need to be able to fly some of these on tech demos.
Space flight is really expensive.
There is intense competition for everything that goes on a spacecraft.
And so it's a big scramble to try to get a new devices that are,
um,
still untested in terms of actually going to another planet or even flying on a
spacecraft.
And so this is really important,
um,
nested multiunit designs where you've essentially got something like we proposed
many years ago.
We called it mother goose and it was a,
a mother robot.
And then we called it the egg crate,
which is where all the little tiny individual robotic units we're going to be
housed.
And at the time we were,
uh,
um,
artificial polymer muscle activated hopping mechanism for these little spheres.
That was an MIT collaboration that we did.
But there are many other ways to do this and we have to solve this problem.
One of our big talents as humans is,
um,
seamlessly putting things together and coming up with creative solutions and our
ability to do a sub cognitive pattern recognition.
And we don't even know how we do it.
I know that,
uh,
there are a lot of folks in the community at large that are trying to mimic this
or uh,
emulate it,
perhaps is a better word.
Um,
we need this.
And really the direction that we have to go is in machine learning and pattern
recognition and coupling that to our devices.
Being able to make real time decisions in the scientific context.
They have to be our surrogates more than just in mobility.
They have to make decisions about which of their tools to deploy.
We cannot tell them everything.
We can help them.
We can,
um,
be with them as a virtual reality presentation perhaps,
but we need them to be us in some of these environments.
And we are,
uh,
not even close.
This is one area that I'm hoping Silicon Valley will magically help with even
though of course we have folks in Nasa who are working on it too.
So this is,
uh,
an area of very active interest in,
in collaboration and then things that we can't directly sense magnetic fields,
chemical gradients,
all of these things that we do not a sense because it's not part of our
particular biological history.
So capturing that a pattern recognition and machine learning technology and then
really trying it out in some of these environments that I showed you that we
work in here,
that connection is very loose.
It's expensive to do that.
Um,
extreme environment expeditions are expensive enough to begin with.
And then when you're taking a prototype,
a technology out there where,
you know,
it's breaking down all the time,
these are very,
very complicated.
And one of the issues is that it's very hard to get enough money to do one of
these projects.
Right?
And then the last problem of course,
is this planetary protection.
If you
do not do this well,
you and enhance the signal to noise problem in terms of looking for,
um,
rare life in an extreme environment on another planet.
If you find it and it's very similar to us in chemistry and you have not done
the planetary protection well,
you have broken that logical chain where you can actually cleanly claim that
what you have found is extra terrestrial,
maybe it's contamination you took with us,
with you.
Um,
so there is a scientific rationale and then there is a deep ecology rationale,
which is you don't want to threaten another biosphere.
Nasa focuses heavily on the science aspect and leaves the ethical aspect to
others.
But many of us within the agency and in the community of course are very
concerned.
We're all conservation minded.
We value our own biosphere as well as everybody else's.
One of the problems that we have is that between the time that we actually flew
the Viking missions to Mars and uh,
now we've had fabulous developments in electronics and all kinds of materials
and engineering components.
The problem is for space flight to biologically sensitive potential targets.
Those have not been developed with an eye to how they can actually be
sterilized.
You can't stick everything in,
uh,
heat and pressure chamber like an autoclave and have that device survive and
still function.
So we have fundamental incompatibilities between the classic ways that we
sterilize things as microbiologists on earth.
And the other aspect is we have to also have ultra clean conditions.
So it's not enough to just kill off anything that is there.
You also have to have your spacecraft scrupulously clean so that here again,
you don't get a signal to noise problem.
You don't get contamination,
even if you're not looking for life.
Even a,
your devices that are looking for the background chemistry,
the mineralogy,
uh,
still cannot be interfered with,
but with,
um,
an unclean spacecraft.
And of course,
I'm sure you know that spacecraft get a cleaned within an inch of their life,
whether they're sterilized or not.
Right?
So the ways people do these two things are not compatible.
People have said often,
Oh gee,
why don't you just go to the,
uh,
you know,
the BLS for containment facilities that the,
Center for Disease Control areas where they work on stuff like Ebola and so
forth.
Well that's great for the sterilization and working with,
um,
you know,
organisms,
but it isn't going to clean things up for you at all.
CDC facilities in terms of spacecraft.
Cleanline does our pig sties right?
So it's not the same thing.
And these have not been worked together,
so not going to go through these,
but just so you know,
we have a lot of tools,
right?
We have the teat dry heat,
steam,
heat,
uh,
we can beat the dickens out of things mechanically.
We can use all kinds of gases and so forth,
uh,
to chemically sterilize.
We can smack it with various kinds of radiation.
But how do you assure that all of those different things are compatible within
subsystems of devices,
a super systems of devices,
or even indeed the whole spacecraft.
So it becomes a massive,
complex systems engineering problem for which we have not tooled up.
And so therefore,
the planetary protection protocols that are implemented now are unreasonably
expensive in many cases.
There really can be an impediment to spacecraft.
We've seen this play out with our upcoming Mars 2020 mission,
trying to meet all the demands of a planetary protection while at the same time
using components that are of mixed materials,
um,
and trying to put all these things together.
It's very complicated and frankly we're just not masters of the art of this.
And so that has cost consequences,
which means we can go as many places.
So we really need a sea change and this is gradually happening,
but it's very slow because people are used to doing things the way they're used
to doing them.
Right?
So my preferred solution is that we design these planetary protection
requirements in as high level engineering requirements.
You don't add them on at the end where it's really expensive.
It's like if you're building a house and you've got two bathrooms planned and
uh,
when they're about to start putting up the drywall,
you go,
you know,
I really think we need a third guest bathroom.
That's like the worst way you can build a house.
Right?
And it's precisely analogous to the way we have to put spacecraft together.
There are many things that have not been tried and I list a couple of them down
here.
So,
um,
the cruise phase,
while you're actually in space getting to wherever you're going,
can you have ways to restart ally's those components while you're actually
flying while you in a non biological environment?
Um,
use of new materials that might facilitate a either trapping micro organisms and
immobilizing them or killing them and causing them to mineralize to see co two
and water.
Who knows?
Uh,
but those things are uh,
are on the horizon and we need to um,
explore that.
So if we are able to stumble our way forward with,
um,
a measure of a good sense and cleverness,
serendipity and a synergy and solve these problems,
then we stand a much better chance of finding life on these missions.
That costs a lot of money.
It costs at least a billion dollars just for the bus ticket to get out to the
outer solar system.
That's just to get there.
That's not the payload or anything you're going to do.
Um,
you could send a brick that far and it would cause co cost that much.
So let me come back to the original theme.
Uh,
and that's the tricorder.
Can we really develop it?
Well,
maybe over time we're willing to settle for something much less developed than
the science fiction version.
Um,
one of the things that,
uh,
maybe called for in a,
in a proposal call fairly soon is the baby step of taking an imaging capability
and a significant chemistry capability and melding those into a conjoined unit
to do two things well without interfering with each other in the same device.
So that's the level at which we find ourselves.
I've tried to paint a picture for you of where I think we need to go.
Um,
so are we ready to go find life on Europa?
We're ready to go look at some of the habitability of properties of Europa,
but we are not ready yet for the life detection.
So this is the kind of a growth area within technology that provides us with a
unique and fascinating problem to have people exercise their brain cells and
come up with solutions.
But all of the things that I've described have real world applications.
The ability to detect life obviously has many applications in terms of um,
uh,
detecting pathogens against a background that's biologically rich against the
background,
this biologically poor,
um,
for a national defense or terrorism,
uh,
circumstances,
um,
epidemics,
things of that sort.
So this is not simply a only devoted to this main,
uh,
exciting,
core function that we have within NASA,
which is exploration of our,
of our universe and the,
and the search for life amongst that exploration.
But it also is something that can act as a,
as a major technology driver.
And with that I'll end.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I'm happy to take questions if,
uh,
if there are any.
Thank you.
Um,
so you've got these painted very broad and diverse picture of what life can be.
And even if we just look at the kind of organic chemistry of life is such a,
such a spectrum from simple,
um,
you know,
the amino acid complex proteins all the way through to complex life and kind of
I guess on a six,
it's been easy in the past to say,
okay,
once it's life that we recognize,
then we can kind of go from there.
That's right.
If,
if we,
if we now kind of broadly now,
do you think there could be life on earth the we haven't recognized as life?
Yeah.
That has been suggested.
I don't know if you're familiar with the,
uh,
the work that Paul Davies who is a physicist at,
um,
University of Arizona.
Um,
he's a very creative guy and he has suggested that maybe there's a shadow
biosphere,
that we actually have organisms here that we're not detecting because they're so
different from us.
I don't know what to think about that.
I mean,
I can argue it either way.
If it is something very different from us,
our ability to recognize it is clearly a,
we're biased against it.
On the other hand,
there are ecological principles that have been developed.
Why observation?
Uh,
you know,
150 years of biological development,
one of them is called the competitive exclusion principle.
I don't know whether that applies to whole classes of organisms.
I mean,
the idea of that principle is that any two species,
if they're competing for exactly the same niche,
somebody will lose and somebody will win over time.
Is that always true?
Can that be balanced?
Are there circumstances where those could be symbiotic relationships?
Or is it as if you have a super imposed system that is so different and is not
tapping into the same resources?
So there actually is no interactivity,
in which case then maybe,
um,
actually Steve Benner who,
uh,
was one of the people who's involved in a national research council study that
was done a number of years ago.
It had a big long official name,
but we all call it the weird life study.
And,
uh,
they were looking at those,
those issues,
you know,
how out there could life be and us still the tactic.
So could it be made out of silicon?
Could it be organic materials that we know,
but you know,
with uh,
anhydrous ammonia is a solvent,
could it be,
um,
solid state?
Could it be,
you know,
all these other things that,
that,
that we are not.
And um,
and so we're still at the very much speculative stage.
So I think actually modeling might,
uh,
you know,
ecological modeling might actually give us more insight than what we can
actually observe.
Um,
Paul Davies and Steve Banner,
you know,
maybe right about a shadow biosphere or it may be just notion.
Um,
I think that if anybody stands a chance of finding something like that,
it's people like us who are in weird environments where we see things.
I showed you the weird message stocking thing.
We don't know whether that has DNA.
We don't know because we're looking at it against a background of other
organisms.
So when we do the genetics,
we got this long list of strains that are not known to science.
If you can't grow them.
And I've been trying to grow them for a long time,
um,
and have failed.
Uh,
I don't know who they are,
so,
you know,
maybe they're made out of non DNA.
I don't know yet.
So it's a very slow process.
So it was a long winded answer to your question,
but it's a very profound question.
Yeah,
thanks.
Great.
Yeah,
my pleasure.